en este vídeo me gustaría
familiarizarnos con un concepto llamado
límite y es súper importante y realmente
tan importante que es una gran base
cuando se empieza a estudiar cálculo
pero realmente mi intención en este
vídeo es que tengamos simplemente la
idea para que más adelante podamos
formalizar más este concepto así que
vamos a dibujar una función una función
tanto simple entonces vamos a definir
qué f x va a ser igual
f x va a ser igual a tener x menos 1 en
la parte del numerador y en la parte del
denominador x menos 1 y podrías decirme
hey pero nosotros estamos teniendo
exactamente lo mismo en el numerador
como en el denominador entonces esto es
algo que se divide asimismo y a su vez
esto sería igual a 1 y si nosotros
podemos simplificar esto y quedaría
todavía más sencillo pero esto hasta
cierto punto es totalmente cierto puesto
que esta función no está definida para
cuando x es igual a 1 puesto que si
establece es que x sea igual a 1 vamos a
tener por acá tendríamos sociedad efe
efe de 0 no perdón no sería efe decir
sean efe de 1 en donde no está permitido
entonces tendríamos que f de 1 lo que
pasaría es que sería 1
-1 nos va a dar 0 arriba y en la parte
del denominador también tendríamos 0 y
para este tipo de casos esto no está
definido para ningún número que esté
dividido entre 0 incluso en el mismo 0
esto está definido entonces esto estará
indefinido así que tú puedes realizar la
simplificación y podrás decir podrás
decir que fx es lo mismo que 1 pero
tendrías que añadir la restricción de
que x no puede ser igual a 1 y ahora
está y está ambas son equivalentes ambas
van a ser iguales a 1 para todos los
demás valores que tome x a excepción de
1 pues como ya habíamos comentado
anteriormente para este caso va a estar
indefinido y entonces ahora hay que ver
cómo podríamos nosotros graficar dicha
función así que vamos a comenzar a
graficar la esta sería este sería
nuestro eje de las leyes y es igual a
efe x como eje y luego y luego vamos a
tener por acá a mi eje de las x y vamos
a decir que
es el punto vamos a decir que este es el
eje de las equis y este es el punto
cuando x es igual a 1 luego bien de este
lado tendríamos cuando x corresponde al
valor menos 1 y por acá tendríamos
cuando ya es igual a 1 y podríamos decir
que también tenemos por acá ayer cuando
vale menos 1 pero no es tan importante
para esta función entonces vamos a
continuar graficando nuestra función y
veamos que para cualquier valor que x
tome la función se va a comportar de la
siguiente forma viene recorriendo todos
valores de x como una constante y para
cuando x es igual a 1 que no está
definido vamos a tener aquí un pequeño
espacio y dicho símbolo del espacio nos
va a representar que dicha función no
está definida ahí y pues como sabemos no
lo estará y entonces esta definición no
nos está diciendo que hacer por lo que
literalmente está indefinida para cuando
x es igual a 1 y entonces esta es la
función que tendremos y pues una vez más
si yo te preguntara cómo se comporta f
de 1 tú ya sabrás que es una función
para la cual no tenemos algo definido en
él
y estaríamos entonces diciendo que dicho
valor es una pequeña brecha en nuestra
función que está justo aquí entonces efe
de uno está indefinido pero hoy ahora
viene la pregunta qué pasaría si yo te
preguntará cuál es la función que se
aproxima cuando x es igual a 1 y es
justo aquí donde tomamos la idea de lo
que es un límite porque lo que nos
interesa es ver qué tanto se acercan las
equis a dicho valor a uno qué tanto se
puede acercar x a uno a medida que más y
más y más hacer que a uno y sería
fijarnos en cómo se comporta o cuál es
la función aproximada y esto es ver poco
a poco cuál es la función que se
aproxima y por el lado izquierdo si
observamos tenemos que ver qué tan cerca
estás de uno al igual que por el lado
derecho pero obviamente dónde fx nunca
es uno y nos podríamos familiarizar un
poco más con la idea pero yo creo que es
importante realizar más ejemplos para
aclararlos y terminando con este hay que
ver cómo se comporta para cuando x se
aproxima a 1 dicha función entonces
aunque todavía no aparece
un tanto tangible dicho límite va a ser
igual a 1 puesto que cada vez nos
estamos acercando más a este valor en su
totalidad y en este caso con esta
función es un tanto fácil compararlo con
la igualdad que teníamos anteriormente
dado que estamos hablando de un límite
cuando x aproxima a 1 en fx y ahorita
podemos ver un poco esta anotación un
tanto idéntica o hipotética puesto que
estamos empezando a mirar la función de
una forma más aproximada a un valor al
cual no está definido pero vamos a tomar
otro ejemplo donde podamos tratar con
una curva y este te quede con una idea
más general así que digamos que tenemos
una función ahora en lugar de llamar la
fx solo por cambiar de notación la
llamaremos gx y decimos que tenemos
dicha función g de x la cual va a estar
definida como x cuadrada para cuando los
x son distintos a 2 para cuando x son
distintos a 2 y vamos a decir que es
igual a 1 para cuando x vale 2 entonces
tenemos una función bastante interesante
que como puedes darte cuenta no es
completamente con
pues tiene una cierta discontinuidad y
vamos a graficar la para que se
visualice mejor entonces por aquí vamos
a tener nuestro eje de las yes nuestro
eje de las 10 y este será nuestro eje de
las x así que ahora vamos a dibujar los
puntos importantes dentro de la gráfica
entonces aquí tenemos x igual a 1 x
igualados y de este lado x igual a menos
1 y x igual a menos 2 y vamos a realizar
la gráfica para todos los valores de x
excepto para cuando vale 2 entonces
vemos que este es una cónica y sería una
parábola y entonces se va a comportar de
la siguiente forma sale del origen y
viene de este lado abriendo así y aquí
en este punto no está definida para
conexión es igual a 2 pero creo que
puedo dibujar la mejor vamos a tratar de
hacerla un poco más simétrica que
respeten los ejes y muchas veces no es
tan importante el dibujo pero no voy a
hacer que aquí nos ocurre algún error
entonces es mejor dibujarlo bien
entonces ésta nos representa la gráfica
de x cuadrada y es para cuando x es
distinto de 2 son todos aquellos valores
d
distintos dedos y entonces se comportan
de esta forma y ahora hay que ver qué
pasa para cuando no está definido para
cuando x vale 2 entonces nuestra gráfica
se vería de la siguiente manera y
entonces una vez más para cuando x es
igual a 2 tendremos una especie de
discontinuidad por aquí por lo que este
dibujo justo aquí tendrá una brecha que
la represente entonces si vemos que
nuestra función dice que está definida
como 1 para cuando x es igual a 2
entonces respetando la escala tendríamos
por aquí que x cuadrada 2 al cuadrado
sería 4 entonces tendríamos por aquí el
4 y nuestro 1 vendría comportándose por
aquí y quizá te parezca una función un
poco bizarra pero lo importante es que
mantengamos la idea de lo que queremos
definir y entonces esto es lo que nos
define nuestra gráfica gtx para cuando x
es distinto de 2 toma los valores de x
cuadrada y para cuando x es igual a 2
ésta va a ser
y entonces esta define nuestra función
fx digo más bien eje x entonces tomamos
x cuadrada para todos aquellos valores
distintos de 2 y 1 para cuando x es
igual a 2 y vemos qué queda a una
distancia o una brecha a un tanto
separada de nuestra gráfica de x
cuadrada con respecto al 1 y ahora si
observas tenemos algo interesante por
analizar entonces hay que realizar unas
cuestiones respecto a nuestra gráfica si
registramos la función para cuando x es
igual a 2 hay que ver cómo se
comportaría entonces tenemos que esto va
a tomar un valor de 1 entonces g de 2 va
a ser igual a 1 y ahora la otra pregunta
también interesante sería cuál es el
límite cuando x se aproxima a 2 de
nuestra función g x así es cuál sería el
límite de nuestra función g x cuando x
se aproxima a 2 y una vez más esta es
una anotación hipotética pues estaríamos
preguntándonos algo donde realmente no
está definida nuestra función pero aquí
en realidad no estamos sino tan
estrictos con
y de apuesto que más adelante seremos
más rigurosos con nuestro concepto
entonces ahora hay que ver qué tanto nos
podemos aproximar a dos osea que si
tomáramos un valor por la izquierda no
sé por ejemplo 1.99 o 1.999 o 1.9 1999
etcétera
cuál es el gx aproximado y ahora si
hablamos de un valor aproximado para la
dirección por la derecha podríamos tomar
otro valor que dijéramos que fueran dos
puntos 2.1 o 2.0 12.00 1 y también ver
qué tanto se aproxima a nuestra función
y podríamos verlo e irlo visualizando al
ir dibujando la gráfica de eje x y
obteniendo valores cada vez más cercanos
a nuestro 2 y aquí como puedes observar
entre más nos acerquemos a este valor la
gráfica se aproxima a nuestro punto de
la brecha entonces incluso aún así la
función tiene este brinco en el 1 y
bueno aquí como podrás ver ya iguale el
límite
al valor de 4 puesto que ya estamos
tratando de acercarnos o aproximarnos a
dicho valor entonces ahora está
calculando y bueno voy a sacar mi
calculadora vamos a meterle algunos
valores numéricos para que tú puedas
visualizarlo así que cómo vamos a
aproximarnos a 2 vamos a decir que ahora
en esta parte vamos a tomar un valor de
1.9 y lo elevamos al cuadrado y como ves
esto nos arroja un valor de 3.61 ahora
1.99 y elevándola al cuadrado nos arroja
un valor un poco más cercano a 4 y vamos
a hacerlo ahora para 1.999 9 y también
elevamos al cuadrado y si te darás
cuenta ya prácticamente esto es 4
entonces cada vez nos aproximamos más a
este valor ahora qué pasaría si
exageramos nuestra cifra y elevamos
todos estos 1.90 y tantos al cuadrado y
vemos que aquí ya nos da 4 pero en
realidad lo que está haciendo la
calculadora es redondear lo porque no es
realmente 4 es un valor mucho muy
cercano pero nunca es 4 y podemos hacer
lo mismo en la otra dirección
utilizaremos ahora
un número por debajo del 2 y trataremos
de aproximar lo entonces vamos a meter
aquí en la calculadora un valor de 2.1 y
lo elevamos al cuadrado vemos que nos
arroja 4.41 y ahora ya vámonos algo un
poquito más rápido saltando algunos
pasos y vamos a tener que 2.000 uno es
este valor y ya cada vez es más cercano
a 4 entonces cómo vemos lo más cercano
lo posiblemente más cercano a 12 es lo
que estamos tratando de forzar para
obtener entonces una vez más esta es una
forma de verlo numéricamente ver el
comportamiento del límite cuando nuestra
función de x se aproxima a 2 y lo que
hace esencialmente es estar cada vez más
cercano a 4